ja also ich habe zuerst habe ich gedacht
dass ein witz als ich das zur kenntnis
genommen aber es ist eigentlich kein
witz sondern man sei traurig dass es das
gibt und das lässt tief blicken
eine künstlerin von der ich vorher noch
nie was gehört hat ronja malzahn ist von
friday is for future ausgeladen worden
bei einer kundgebung bei der
veranstaltung aufzutreten so weit so gut
wie können wir ein und ausladen wen sie
wollen aber der grund ist interessant
sie ist ausgeladen worden wegen ihrer
frisur sie hat dreadlocks da kann man
das sehr sehr gut kennt und das geht gar
nicht denn sie ist eine weiße dreadlocks
dürfen aber in der anschauung von links
verblendeten menschen von juristen nur
schweizer haben weil bis zu deren kultur
kurt macht es ein weisser hat dann weiß
er diese frisur so habe ich heute
richtig verstanden dann ist das in
gewisser weise rassistisch weil man sich
die kultur aneignet obwohl man sie nicht
durchlebt und auch nicht alles durchlebt
hat was mit der kultur an schrecklichen
dingen geschehen ist da frage ich mich
allerdings schon wo wir angekommen sind
wo intoleranz und sohn inquisitorische
ton und sind durch debatten durchzieht
und ja nicht nur die debatten damit
könnte man als streitlustiger menschen
noch leben sondern jemand der diese idee
nicht folgt die da verbreitet wird der
wird sofort gecancelt ausgeladen
bekämpft gegen ihn wird gehetzt agitiert
twitter wird explodiert und es hat
eigentlich gar keinen richtigen sinn
mehr wenn man in der öffentlichkeit sein
will oder im privaten umfeld in solchen
privaten umfeld die abweichende meinung
zu vergeben wir wollen diesen an eigenen
von kultur noch einmalig verspricht ganz
kurzen stückchen näher treten das
bedeutet also wenn ich das weiter denke
weiße und schwarze dürfen jetzt auch
nicht mehr mit stäbchen essen weil das
fehlende kulturelle aneignung aus dem
asiatischen raum ist und bestimmt
irgendein schlimmer asiate der mit
stäbchen gegessen hat man jemand anderen
unterdrückt hat noch eindeutiger ist es
ein rap musik dürfen eigentlich nur
schwarze machen alles andere verbietet
sich ist eine kulturelle aneignung und
diese beispiele legen den brutalen
denkfehler der intoleranten und
inquisitoren offen
aneignung ist nämlich nichts schlechtes
sondern was positives aneignung
geschieht oft aus wertschätzung aus
dient dem austausch aneignung etwas
positives aneignung schafft verbindung
und deshalb wäre mein rat an freies for
future ganz eindeutig ladet diese
künstlerinnen jetzt wieder ein und zwar
wegen ihrer dreadlocks sonst seid ihr
der vorposten einer entwicklung in
deutschland wie nordkorea dort sind
nämlich nur 15 frisuren erlaubt
ich habe ein bisschen unbehagen über
frisuren zu sprechen
und ich frage mich warum wir uns damit
beschäftigen weil sie ihren blicken
lässt warum diese
ich sage diese bewegung teilweise diese
regimes geworden ich rede jetzt hier
nicht vom freitag futures wohl da auch
anzeichen und da gibt es aber wenn wir
über identitätspolitik was alles
progressive linke genannt werden
progressiv sind sie nicht wenn man in
den usa an schaut und sagt was das mit
dem diskus kultur getan hat wie
gespalten ist das land dann muss man
nicht nur trump erwähnen sondern auch
diese art von linke die in den letzten
jahren auch in deutschland fuß gefasst
hat und nicht nur mit frisur und so
umgeht sondern mit professoren an
universitäten sie seit 20 jahren zu
afrika forschen und nur weil wir sind
jetzt keine vorträge halten sollen die
verteilung von menschen in schwarz und
weiß diese zentralisierung auf hautfarbe
was fünften ja immer wieder gemacht
haben tun sie im namen von anti
rassismus und das ist für mich keine
anti rassismus sondern eine entwicklung
die uns nicht versöhnt nicht zusammen
bringt nicht die leute dazu bewegt über
rassismus nachzudenken sondern es wird
zementiert was schon in der gesellschaft
ist und sogar teilweise radikalisiert
ich würde ganz einsturz widersprechen so
seien nicht in der im inhalt sondern
einfach in der aussage dass da irgendwas
dann links sei es ist nichts da an links
weil man sich nicht vernünftig streiten
kann oder an intoleranz ist nicht links
guter punkt das finde ich blöd man muss
über dinge reden man kann übrigens
durchaus sensibel sein in der wortwahl
und sowas das kann man alle sein bin ich
auch aber finde dieses unterdrücken von
debatten oder gar zusagen bestimmte
leute dürfen sie an debatte nicht
beteiligen weil sie eine bestimmte
biografie das ist das gegenteil unser
problem in deutschland ist doch nicht
vielfalt sondern ein zeit und das ist
ziemlich einfältig sozusagen in solchen
kategorien zu denken deswegen kann ich
nur sagen in deutschland gibt es
übrigens meinungsfreiheit bei uns wird
man nicht im knast gesteckt man darf
sagen was man will und mancher twitter
war ein aspekt an manche twitter storm
ist ein sternchen sozusagen also man
hält das auch aus mir geht es uns auch
mal von einer seite so unterzogen es
gibt jetzt keine parteien mehr erkennen
nur noch deutschen jetzt zu den waffen
gegriffen wenn du geh'n wir in anderen
bereichen auch also ich finde ein
bisschen mehr gelassenheit und
bereitschaft zu streiten ernsthaft zu
streiten dass eine stärke von demokratie
das dürfen sie nämlich nur in
demokratien dürfen sie nicht steigen
wenn das linke stehe ich glaube und das
wäre auch noch meine antwort auch weil
man so warum wir das so wichtig nehme
ich glaube dass darin was zu erkennen
ist was man in einem frühen stadium
nämlich jetzt diskutieren und eigentlich
verhindern muss nämlich der gedanke
der kompletten intoleranz und der
gedanke meine ideologie allen anderen
überzustülpen und verso nicht denkt der
ist irgendwie falsch das gegenteil ist
ja wahr in einer vielfältigen pluralen
gesellschaft dass das andere das
reizvolle ist das andere mich
weiterbringt wenn ich mich also damit
auseinandersetze und ganz konkret in so
fragen
rassismus nicht rassismus was
rassistisch was ist noch nicht
rassistisch was ist an der grenze dazu
ich finde schon dass mir auch wichtig zu
sagen wenn ich das kritisiere was ich
gerade kritisiert habe mir schon wichtig
dass uns das alles auch unsere eigenen
gewohnheiten mal auf den prüfstand leben
legen lässt ja also ich habe
wahrscheinlich als kind und jugendlicher
schon zigeunerschnitzel bestellt und
habe mir nicht die gesamte aufladung
dazu ausgedacht und drüber nachgedacht
also bin ich dankbar dass das geschieht
aber wie bei allen entwicklungen einem
positiven kennen die er oft auch einen
gerechtigkeitssinn als antrieb für sich
verbuchen kommt es dann sehr schnell zu
ungerechtigkeiten und da sozusagen muss
unser stopp schild als gesellschaft
seien besser war mit es wichtig die
frisur von der künstlerin ist mir
eigentlich auch pumpe aber es steht für
was ich bin absolut bei ihnen ich finde
auch politiker correctness kann uns auch
weiterbringen radikale politiker
correctness kann uns wirklich und die
debattenkultur
sturm ich bin sehr erfreut über das was
wir gesagt haben weil ich auch in jeder
partei in den letzten jahren auch eine
gewisse entwicklungen sehe die in diese
richtung gehen vor allem einzelpersonen
natürlich die partei sehr groß aber
diese diese näher zu identitäts
politische haltungen ist in diese partei
wie auch bei den grünen und die linke
ist da und ich hoffe die dürfen
existieren sie dürfen ihre meinung sagen
sie dürfen auch radikal manchmal sich
ausland aber es muss auch ein gegenpol
sein und diese gegenpol wurde in den
letzten jahren entweder massiv
eingeschüchtert oder komplett gekannt
hat und das macht mir sorgen was die
debattenkultur in deutschland wir müssen
lernen weiter zu streiten
leidenschaftlich zu treten und auch
debatten sollen weh tun und wir sollten
auch leute zu hören die vielleicht an
einen anderen brand die für gesellschaft
stehen demokratisch sind aber vielleicht
auch eine konservative meinung hier oder
da haben ja es ist vielleicht auch der
punkt das ist ein bisschen altmodisch
aber dass auch schön ist wenn wir den
argumenten streitet absolut schon
rücksicht nimmt auf biografien von
menschen das schon man muss auch
sensible umgang mit menschen seien aber
ich darf doch niemanden ausschließen
nachdem du bist jetzt ein alter weiß
haben hand und darf sich an bestimmten
debatten gern auch beteiligen das ist
absurd im übrigen gibt es in toleranz ja
in jeder jeder art und weise und
politiker finde ich die dürfen nicht
hauptsächlich über sich selbst reden
und was sie sind sondern das wofür wir
politik machen über die inhalte ja und
da kann jeder der gutes argument kommt
und die klischees stimmen ja meistens
auch nicht ich stimme nicht zwischen
jung und alt und die stimmen nicht man
ist nicht automatisch irgendetwas weil
man dann bestimmten kumpel zugehört und
ging schließlich zu melden das finde ich
positiv insofern bleibe ich dabei dass
nicht links und das ist er intern die
ganze zeit nachgedacht ob es nicht doch
ein bisschen links ein bisschen
weil also der sich einigkeit darüber
dass
extremismus und radikales an allen
ländern
zu verabscheuen ist und abzulehnen ist
aber wenn man über freies for future
spricht
kommen dort wenig rechtsradikale zum
vorschein wahrscheinlich auch geben aber
es ist doch eher wenn ich das sind die
debatte in den letzten wochen verfolgt
habe doch eher der verdacht da dass es
von linksradikalen benutzt wird um sich
verständlich zu machen und um sich in
die debatte einzumischen besser gesagt
um sie an sich zu reißen oder zu
verunmöglichen also ist es schon ein
bisschen links wir können aber
irgendwann mal darüber diskutieren ob es
diese begriffe überhaupt noch gibt und
auch selber realisieren muss man da
sagen moralisierend auftreten ist auch
etwas was nicht gut für die debatten in
eine verrohung der debattenkultur
aufgefallen wir haben gerade darüber
gesprochen also wenn ich aufhöre corona
politik oder wenn ich höre linke politik
oder rechte politik das ist ja auch
nicht stigmatisierung die die ganze zeit
im blick auf die pandemie vorgenommen
wurde also diejenigen die die
maßnahmen die die politischen maßnahmen
in deutschland kritisieren gelten ja mal
sehr schnell als 16 das argument ist
relativ einfach zu entkräften mit dem
verweis darauf wer in stockholm er macht
ist das ist eine sozialdemokratische
regierung und schweden ist jetzt sage
ich mal für so gut wie gar keine krone
maßnahmen bekannt also da einfach zu
sagen das wäre rechtsradikale corona
politik oder das sagen doch nur die
rechten das passt halt einfach das passt
überhaupt nicht in dem kommentar habe
ich glaub ich vor anderthalb jahren
schon mal geschrieben und das passiert
aber bis heute die man teilt das sind
links und rechts ein und wenn ich mir
wenn ich gerade daran denke an die
einstufung oder die das nun dass man
sagt linke politik linke corona politik
dann würde ich doch da eigentlich
erwarten dass man gerade die sozial
schwachen im blick hat und nicht einfach
mehr oder minder blind und willkürlich
lockdown maßnahmen verhängt die ja vor
allem die sozial schwachen den den
sozialschwachen schaden die leben in
beengten wohnverhältnissen da sind die
sind die bildungsangebote für für kinder
nicht so gut und das sind die die am
meisten unter den maßnahmen leiden und
die das kritisieren sind dann rechts für
mich macht diese ganze debatte wenn sie
mich zur ausgangsfrage nochmal zurück
das ist keine debatte das ist in ordnung
eine stigmatisierung die starken männer
geschrieben mit dem mit gesunden
menschen würden haben rechts erklärt
trotzdem ist auch teil der wirklichkeit
darf man auch nicht weil sie es gibt
natürlich bei uns leute rechtsradikal
die solche kreisbürger demonstration
anmelden ja und auch die ah ja auch
hingehen und erzählen dass er bilder
werden kinder entführt und ich haben
anspruch gelesen da hieß es wenn du
wirklich glaubt dass der impfstoff in
einem gen materialeinkauf dann begreift
das als chance das ist eine fläche von
etwas umzugehen was ist ja auch gibt
natürlich aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es
schon etwas komisch dass quasi die die
kritik an dieser er an dieser art von
maßnahmen mehr oder minder nur von
diesen menschen und von der afg gekapert
wurde und eigentlich gibt es genauso gut
politik der grünen der linken und ihrer
spd sein die sagen hey wir dürfen nicht
vergessen wer leidet am meisten unter
den master aber sie wenn ich finde das
nicht drin gegen den staat sagen alles
was der staat mache natürlich nicht
natürlich hier verweigern das und wieder
muss fein halten und sich an die an die
bedingungen bei großen demonstrationen
so was das gibt es halt schon auch und
sie haben aber recht man darf es nicht
pauschalisieren
da muss man sehen dass selbst auch gibt
wurde doch auch von den politikern dass
man sich jetzt mal eben alle sagen ich
finde dass das thema demonstration ein
ganz wichtiges ist und ich finde dass da
in der krone ab anime eigentlich schon
jede demonstration von vornherein von
der politik gesagt wird dass ein
querdenker die gegen die kroner maßnahme
auf die strahler täuschen sie sich aber
wirklich erstens ist bei uns zu gehen
die gerichte sehr streng zu genehmigen
oder nicht und wenn sie eine auflage
machen die heißt sie müssen masken
tragen und sie tun das eben nicht
natürlich greift dann muss der name ist
getragen aber deswegen ist es richtig
wenn der abstand der bei andersrum
standard suchen ist es komisch ist
regionaler hersteller vor ein paar
wochen in hamburg war die korona
maßnahmen gegner demo verboten und die
maßnahmen befürworter oder solidarität
ja fans wie auch immer das war erlaubt
dass das ist doch mit dieser allmacht
oder mehr alles erlauben elena
dementjewa
demonstrationsrecht ist echt wichtig
aber es entscheiden wir uns nicht die
politik sondern die justiz entscheidet
die gucken sich das an war das
verhältnismäßig mit den maßnahmen die da
verlangt worden sind und wenn es das
nicht oder wenn gefahr ausgeht reden sie
mit polizeibeamten die teilweise in den
anfangszeiten von denen bespuckt worden
sind nicht nur in den anfängen wehren
doch jetzt gerade wieder alle banalen
gar nicht bewusst reserve hat recht
indem wir sie aber es gab auch diesen
teil der realität die sollten wir auch
nicht ignorieren und das wenn das ein
paar solcher demonstrationen sind es
waren genug
wo sie gesehen haben müssen sie selber
ja ich habe auch welche gesehen was das
für leute haben gesagt lassen die massen
auf die sie so lange die polizei essen
und reißen wir sie mit und dann gab es
sprechchöre gegen den staat jetzt haben
sich schon die rechten auch versucht
anzueignen teilweise
was mich bei der ganzen demonstrations-
fragerecht bewegt ist ob wir nicht noch
mit einer deutlichen einschränkung eines
anderen grundrechts nämlich das auf
demonstrationsfreiheit zu tun haben weil
wir als normaler mensch der nicht
politisch irgendwie engagiert ist oder
gar einem rand angeordnet sondern der
einfach zu dem thema seine meinung zum
ausdruck bringen will der kann heute
eigentlich gar nicht demonstrieren weil
die gefahr besteht nämlich dass er
hinterher als rechtsradikaler in seinem
job probleme hat rausfliegt geächtet ist
weil wenn er mit seinen 30 freunden in
hamburg oder in bottrop oder sonst wo
auf die straße geht plötzlich irgendein
verrückter reichs bürger durchs bild
geht und jetzt bisschen selbstkritik an
unserem job der wird dann der tagesschau
aufmacher und dann war das plötzliche
reichs bürger demo die ich aus ganz
anderen motiven angemeldet habt also ich
sags ganz offen ich sags ganz offen ich
würde mir im moment eigentlich nicht
trauen eine demonstration zu einem thema
anzumelden und als veranstalter
aufzutreten das so in diesem themen kann
alles und das macht mir wirklich sage
also weil weil wenn das nicht einzeln
wenig einzelschicksal bin okay alles so
aber wenn das die leute beginnt zu
erfassen dass man es eben doch nicht
kann weil man dann missbraucht wird in
der debatte hinterher dann ist es schon
auch ein eingriff in die
meinungsfreiheit weil sie das vorhin und
da bin ich schon wir es gibt in dem land
meinungsfreiheit aber es gibt eben an
einer ein oder anderen stelle schon
dellen in der aber erstens strunz traut
sich alle sind einfach würdigen das
nicht glauben sie sich das nicht trauen
und zweitens die meisten demonstrationen
werden schon eher von linken
veranstaltet ist es ja so also es ist
nicht so typisch dass sozusagen
konservative auf die straße gehen und
demonstrieren ist demonstrieren links
demonstrieren